after months of setbacks on the back
move fronts they are advancing as the
weather improves
we joined the third Brigade and they
wanted to show us how they're forcing
the Russians back
the fighting here remains Fierce and the
last few hundred meters towards the new
front line have to be made on foot
across open grounds
you can hear in the distance the sound
of small arms fire
the crackler machine gun in the distance
the Russian positions are not far away
from here we're now entering the area
the ukrainians took from them
a few days ago
foreign
down here is one of the foxholes that
they were in inside you can see Russian
clothing boots
and everything that they left behind
when this was cleared out
these scratches of Woodland have been
decimated by shrapnel and gunfire
what should be fields of wheat are
pockmarked by the constant shelling
this footage from a helmet camera shows
how the Brigade cleared these areas
infantry using grenades and storming the
positions
some of the Russians fled chased Away by
Bullet and shell
others were captured but many were
killed here in the fighting
is
and as we were leaving they were still
collecting the bodies of Russian
soldiers from the battlefields
horany
attack
foreign
the operations here are a Prelude to
Ukraine's coming counter-offensive it
could start any day now
and at the brigades headquarters they
scan the landscape for Russian movements
but despite Ukraine's success in recent
days Russia still controls 90 of back
moves
they show us a drone live stream of the
city
and the damage is horrific
this place is now a smoking ruin
the soldiers here though are confident
they can win back their country but any
Victory will take time
optimistic
we know what we are doing we know how we
must uh doing uh
our attack or our defense we know that
in the end maybe two three five years I
don't know we will win this world
sponsor offensive comes is still a
guessing game even for the troops on the
grounds
but they know their time is coming
and they say they are ready
Alex Rossi Sky News on the back boot
fronts